Task queues allows you to take the job offline, so
you can create the task queue and then add a
hundred task that each has the job to send a
hundred emails. Tasks can be created for many user activity,
and be put on this queue. And as we will
see later, these tasks are not executed in the user
request strip. So you can immediately return a response to
the user, but one question remains then. How will these
mails be sent? That actually depends on the type of queue you use. But before we
go into that, it's time for you to answer a question. So the question is which
is best to use, the HTTP request thread
or task queues? When you want to generate
the report, or register a new user, checking
out the shopping cart, or do photo face recognition?